you
we know that people who fit in enjoy
their work they enjoy the experience of
being in an organization they're
emotionally rewarded by it and we all
aspire I I imagine to create
organizations where members of the
organization wake up in the morning and
want to come and where they feel
attached and indebted to the
organization and mostly indebted to
their peers and and and by creating a
healthy cultural environment we can
facilitate that
it's the experience of coming to an
entirely different cultural context that
makes visible to you how pervasive
culture is but also how invisible it is
so like an example I always like to use
is when I came to the States for the
first time and people would say to me
let's have coffee sometime and I would
take that as a literal invitation to
having coffee sometime and I didn't
quite understand that it was in fact
like a very nice pleasant way to finish
a conversation but where the intention
is actually I don't want to have coffee
with you
but let's just pretend that we had a
nice interaction and that so I would I
would initially respond by saying oh
yeah sure let's have coffee sometime
when it took me a while to figure out
that that wasn't the intention of the
speaker and it's only when you're kind
of transposed to very different cultural
settings that suddenly your lack of
cultural skill becomes apparent to you
and that moment to me and have
highlighted how important but invisible
it is and why it's important for us to
study it
culture is about the systematic
distribution of of beliefs and and
cognitive understandings across a
population and it's very difficult to
measure people's cognition historically
we've been doing this by asking them
questions through surveys the problem is
that surveys are not very good
instruments because we lie to ourselves
we lie to others we sometimes are not
very well attached to our cognition and
especially our unselfconscious cognition
that's what makes it unselfconscious so
and add to that the fact that it's not
very feasible to ask people questions
every day time and again it it leads to
huge attrition and disengagement
you
the internet revolution has made a
variety of behaviors that up until
recently were not recorded recordable
and they leave a trace from how we
communicate online to our purchasing
behaviors everything now leaves a trace
and marry that with the computational
capabilities that we now have our
ability just our ability to compute on
our on our smart phones we now have
computational capabilities that are akin
to what NASA had in 1985 and that was
new machine learning tools artificial
intelligence deep learning the ability
to analyze unstructured complex data and
to reduce it to measurable outcomes both
of these together bring us to the golden
age of cultural analysis
so we were very lucky to have
collaborated with a few organizations
already that we're willing to share
information deriving from the email
exchange amongst employees over a period
of of multiple years by now myself my
colleagues and all the members of our
our lab we've analyzed many many years
of data being exchanged by members of
multiple organizations and there's a lot
of information culturally that we can
derive by looking at how people use
language in their emails
the reason that language is such an
useful way for us to analyze culture is
because language is probably the most
important medium through which cultural
information is is exchanged between
between individuals I'm not interested
in whether when you and I are talking
are we talking about how are we going to
address this particular customer problem
or are we gonna talk about HR issues or
gonna talk about the Christmas party
that's coming up
what functionally were exchanging is
immaterial to the analysis what's
interesting is whether in discussing
these topics were using the same kind of
linguistic styles as a reflection of our
cultural alignment so whether we're
using my aggressive and brief language
or whether we're very apologetic and you
can just think about all your email
exchanges there's a significant
difference between saying dear so-and-so
it was such a pleasure to meet you and I
hope that this is not an intrusion on
your time etc but if you don't mind that
your earliest convenience
can we please meet and you can say the
exact same thing but say hey John can we
meet next week without all of these like
introductions and apologies functionally
you've exchanged the exact same
information but there's a lot of
cultural content embedded in how you
chose to present yourself and and and
the problem and the question and that's
precisely what what our analysis tries
to to infer
you
swear words are very from a symbolic
point of view they're very aggressive
somebody drops an f-bomb
it's noticeable it's not it's not it's
not a subtle thing that people do as I
speak and if you think about the
organizations that you've been in or
their various cultural context in which
you've gone through through your life
there's a lot of variation in terms of
whether it's allowed or really a faux
pas to use swear words in an interaction
and you can imagine that there are
certain organizations where not only do
people swear a lot they use swearing as
a means to project to others their
authority and their tenacity and you can
imagine at the other extreme that there
are organizations where the use of swear
words is perceived as an offensive and
inappropriate way of handling yourself
would be interpreted as aggression so
it's the same use of language but it's
interpreted very differently as a
function of what's normatively
appropriate or inappropriate in these in
these two different settings
in the research that I do and where we
analyze how people use language in their
interactions their habitual way of
speaking inside the organization whether
they swear at the appropriate level is a
very strong signal of the extent to
which they're aligned or misaligned with
the normative expectations of their
peers the mere information about whether
or not an individual is correctly using
language insofar as how language is
being used by others and reflecting
their expectations and beliefs about the
world is a very strong indicator of
whether that person reads the cultural
code and whether conditional having read
it correctly whether that person has the
motivation to behave in a culturally
compliant way
you can imagine that some people realize
that it's inappropriate to swear but
they swear nevertheless and that
decision whether conscious or on self
conscious has a lot of information there
either signaling to others that they
don't want to be part of this group or
they might feel so secure in their
position in the group that they believed
that by behaving in a non conformist way
they can signal to others their
uniqueness without undermining their
position in the organization so there's
a lot of information in these very
subtle and automatic decisions that we
make and how we communicate information
to one another
discoveries on culture are both exciting
and daunting they're exciting because
we're starting to figure out the
constituent components of this opaque
thing that we call culture they're
daunting because we discover how complex
it is how difficult it is to manage and
how not one size fit all or one shot
exercise it is but again they're
exciting because I think were at this
moment where the research can be
translated into insights and into
methodologies and into tools that can
inform managerial decisions in a way
that would make management more
effective and more rewarding to
everybody involved
[Music]